just wanted to say congratulations to  our street scene team for the amazing  job that they always do  they go above and beyond but  particularly they've just been  recognised  in the national apsi awards for their  street cleaning  refusing recycling and grounds  maintenance  they do an amazing job but particularly  this year it's been really tricky  with covid 19 and the pandemic and then  also the challenges of bringing  the recycling collections in-house from  our contractor  they've gone above and beyond and they  provide amazing services  throughout the district so i just want  to say thank you to them  and i hope that residents will join me  in that too